hello everyone and welcome back to the
Magnus Invitational we are back at game
3 between Magnus Carlsen and ali reza
Fallujah the score is now leveled as Ali
Lucia bounced back in rah in game 2 with
that well would that mean sacrifice that
Magnus overlooked and the nice tricky
mate so now again Carlson with the white
pieces well let's see if he sticks to
what he played in the first round or
does he switches to something new so
again he goes for the d4 we have 9 256
c4 e6 Knight to f3 and d5 the Queens
gambit is on the board the same as in
game 1 Knight to c3 and Bishop to b4
going for the rock goes in so alga Reza
was also very happy with what he
achieved and this is what he prepared so
see captures he captures and now Bishop
the f4 so everything the same end in the
game one other reason one for this night
the c6 line that we said that it's
incredibly rare but here he just goes
for castles he decides that it was worth
it worth a shot for maybe one game but
probably cost and checked it after after
they do have a pause after every game so
he switches it up with castles III we
have Bishop to f5 and now Queen to b3
putting pressure on the bishop here also
if you move it you might lose the b7
pawn so nice the c6 defending and now
there is a known game where Fabiano
quran defeated Vishwanath an island with
Bishop to g5 from this year's the Tata
Steel masters but Carson goes for Knight
to h4 instead and it's quite and quite
an interesting idea
you either force the bishop to g6 where
black will lose the bishop pair or
Bishop to e6 what which is a plate and
then you get Bishop to d3 without
trading light square bishop so you get a
nice light square bishop on d3 so very
useful with a 5 by a bio Larissa and now
comes castles by Magnus with Knights to
h5 going after the dark square bishop
and here at Bishop to g3 we have Knight
captures H captures and just Bishop a
back to e7 forcing the night back and
night to 3 so it is it does have the
bishop pair let's see what what Carlson
makes of it with night the b4 goes after
the disappear
now not a bishop to be won but rather
the shop to e to as he's expecting of
course that the Queen will be under
attack store c5 we have a three and now
see for pushing the Queen further back
and now Queen to d1 so holidays are
doing good work with keeping crossings
pieces at bay and Carlson will at some
point of course I create a breakthrough
either with E for or would be three and
he does it right away with sorry and the
night is under attack Knight goes back
to a6 and now III just challenging the
c4 pawn with Knight the c7 and now be
cactus and c4 we have D captors in c4
which gives Carlson an incredibly strong
Center but Alireza gets a past C pawn so
a for not allowing a black to push even
further and also you have the B 5 square
for your knight if needed and it takes
away the be 5 square from blacks Knight
prevents black from connecting his pawns
on the Queen side would be 5 and it's
just a very useful move so Bishop to b4
by holidays are going after the Knight
Queen to c2 and here Ali Riza just takes
the knight we have Bishop Tadros Queen
captures and now Knight to d5 with the
idea that now if you capture the pawn
Knight captures and e3 opens up a
discovery here so this is how allah reza
prepares to get his pawn moving we have
Queen to a3 and now comes Luke to c8
just putting the rogue behind the pass
pawn rook F the c1 and now comes Knight
to be for the knight is very useful here
you of course want to start pushing it
and if you push it all the way to C 2
which will be excellent as the knight
would already defend it so rip the c3
magnus prevents the pond from being
pushed but now Knight back to d5 a
forcing the rook back here Magnus was
rook to c1 and now we have Knight back
to B for all that Reza says I'm very
happy we draw with black either we
repeat or you come up with something
else
and here Magnus instead goes tonight the
e5 and now he wants to meet c3 with the
knight back to d3 and this is exactly
what holidays are goes for c3 and if you
capture it then you get for example if
route captures on c3 then you have
this very annoying night to see to move
just attacking the the Queen and the
rook and after you trade for example
here the the fork remains so that's the
problem behind the seats removed so
Magnus just goes night to d3 and now
Queen to b6 still just connecting rooks
developing the Queen and again if you
for example if you try it now now it
doesn't really change anything still
Knights the sea tube and the idea is the
same only now the rogue defends it so we
have rook a to be won by Magnus now not
allowing the knight to move and here now
is where Alireza should have gone pawn
to see to it would give him a nice
protected passed pawn and c2 which is
simply incredible and force the rook to
either move or to give up the exchange
here sorry the dick cheney's would work
characters and before but it will be a
very uncomfortable position for Magnus
however it is a first decided to improve
the position with the bishop to f5 looks
very strong however this allows the
Magnus to solve this problem and the
problem of the C pawn simultaneously so
he just goes the rook to b3 and now
there actually is a threat of rope
captors because night the c2 no longer
is possible so here I wrestle a bunch of
characters and III we have bishop
character son b3 and now he played c2
but now it's just a free point there's
not not much you can do here so Magnus
capture it with the rook of course the
knight cannot capture because the Queen
hangs so rook captures and c2 Bishop
characters and now Queen to c6 with a
double attack on the bishop but Bishop
to f5 we have Queen to d5 but now Bishop
to g4 with ideas of shifting the bishop
operative three or maybe even e 2 and
just jamming it or over to b5 and now it
is I stuck playing this endgame a night
against the bishop being a pawn down so
like the c2 attacking the Queen Queen
back to be to now attacking the pawn
here and now our ISA blocks it once
again now you cannot give up the the b7
pawn rook the c3 just getting the roof
to a nice open file in the b6 now we
have Bishop to e2 preparing to bring the
bishop
or to b5 and now comes or maybe just
hoping for a 5 and maybe maybe I'll get
as a blunder is the Queen
however hardly and here we have Queen to
f5 and now just a very nice active
square for the Queen also prevents some
expansion with E 4 we look back to C 1
and now comes g6 making some breathing
room for the Queen for King before you
bring the rook into the game and worship
the b5 now taking care of the e4 pawn
and now it's just a very very solid
position you want to bring your queen to
the center of the board and then slowly
but surely start pushing your pawns
so rook the c8 challenging rook but
Magnus is more than happy to trade we
have rook captures with Czech Queen
captures and now Queen to d2 ready to
start pushing those pawns
so Queen to f5 for the moment preventing
it but now f3 the King is now also
coming to help out with the pushing of
the pawns Queen g5 not allowing the push
as the Queen would Hank
so King f2 and now Knight to d5 but
Queen D 3 and now preparing efore with
h5 by fuchsia in the now II for
attacking the knight Knight before and
now Quinta III of course Magnus is very
happy to trade Queens he does have a
past deep on so Queen to f6 blocking not
walking but just avoiding the Queen
trade and now Queen to c3 we have King
to h7 and now f4 so now even better as a
5 and d5 are coming so Queen ISA going
after the pawn here and here Magnus has
to decide what to do d5 is actually a
very nice resource here because after
captures d6 is coming you don't have
anything here where black d7 will be
protected another reason why the bishop
on b5 is very useful will you will just
have a protected passed pawn here
however Magnus goes for the nice
tactical idea Queen to c4 he offers the
e well basically he offers a queen trade
but he offers the d4 pawn for the f7
pawn and here all there is a knows that
this is his only chance at least cousins
King is a little bit open so if you take
into account to the previous game who
knows what might happen
so Queen captures on f7 with
King h6 and now Queen to f6 by Magnus
keeping an eye on the pond but also with
some very nasty threats for example if
black plays a careless move and Queen h8
is checkmate as the pond covers g5 so
after Queen to have sex with King to h7
not allowing this and now Queen e5 again
caused an offer offers the Queen trade
Queen C to check in now King g1 you want
to hire King over to h2 Queen to d2 and
now comes King to h2 and now you really
don't have a lot of options here for a
moment you cannot cross the five but
something like a Bishop to c4 and the
pond will be definitely able to cross
this but black has other problems not
not just the past deep one so tonight's
the c2 going after the pawn but now
Magnus just nicely finishes it with
Queen to e7 check we have king to h6
Queen to f8 check King to h7 and now of
course you might even pause the video
now while I give you a few seconds to
find the finishing touch here to win the
game with white so for those of you who
are able to do it congratulations and
spotting the the mating pattern and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show its burst of the c4 and after
Magnus played this it was in this
position unmoved 58 that our is a
fuchsia resigned the game and third game
goes to Magnus which means the result is
now two-to-one in Carlson's favor and
here of course he resigns because
whatever you do doesn't really matter
runs into Bishop g8 check you have to go
here and now this mating pattern which
if you don't know you should remember it
as it you'd be surprised how often you
will have it in your own games a
discovered check for syncing to h7 now
Queen g8 check King has to go here and
finishing with Queen to g6 checkmate so
after Bishop to c4 all areas are
resigned and another excellent victory
for Magnus and nowadays is in a position
where he absolutely has to win Game four
with the white pieces to get back into
the match and to take the match into
Armageddon
so we'll see what happens that's the
game I do hope you enjoyed it I would
like to thank Phil if eventual 10 insta
marketing's Everett Mulder Joshua not
and Lord
mayor for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
video Sara thank y'all for watching and
I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Magnus
Invitational so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day